we have more threats to food insecurity
than i think we've ever had in in
humanity
today there are 48.9
million people
that are on the brink of famine
we know that people are dying today
because there's a lack of food
the war in ukraine has destabilized the
world as it relates to food it is not
just a war against ukraine it is a war
against humanity
and many countries are suffering and
millions of people are going to suffer
even more because of this war
we're having to cut food rations
imagine telling your child that they're
going to go from two meals a day down to
one it's devastating
there are multiple factors right now
that are impacting the world food
program and our ability
to get food to those who are
significantly
malnourished hungry and on the brink of
famine
so pre-covered years we talked about
famine but it was relatively rare
today we have this domino effect
of climate and coveted and cost and
conflict and they're all beating up on
each other
we obviously have conflict right now in
the ukraine but there's conflict in
other countries other countries that are
a bit forgotten right now including
yemen i would also add afghanistan and
and many others
the global economy coming into this was
already
in a bit of a stress situation because
of covet and the impact of the past
couple of years on
shipping and on production
and covert really knocked down the
supply chain as you can imagine and that
had dramatic consequences on
communities that are really hungry
covet is is still a crisis in many
countries
and it's forcing lockdowns and a
lockdown means that a small older farmer
a small
business a a female entrepreneur is not
able to take their product that they've
harvested to the open market
because of lockdowns
climate is kind of a twofold problem
number one it is a lack of rain there
are so many countries right now that are
not seeing any rain at all which
basically makes it impossible for them
to harvest and to keep livestock
alive
the other piece is that you've got
hurricanes that hit
these countries time and time again
costs are going up they're going up so
that food is becoming less affordable
for people here in the united states but
in particular people who are about to
enter the phase of starvation around the
world
to take the individual
around the world in a less developed
country living on a dollar 90 a day
you can't survive when you're earning
1.90 a day and the cost of food has gone
up by 50
ukraine is known as the bread basket of
the world
for an organization like the world food
program
50 of our wheat came from ukraine
there's enough food between corn maize
and wheat and oil that's stored in silos
or on container ships in ukraine to feed
400 million people
imagine if we can't get that food to
those who are starving to those who are
hungry it is going to have a devastating
effect on the world
given the blockade of the
ports well
it's blockade but it's it's also that
the ports are essentially being targeted
they're they're under attack
they're they're completely inoperable i
would call it more of that than actually
a blockade they've just been completely
shut down
so i don't have an immediate solution at
all apart from
stop the war in ukraine there's no
reason to have a war in ukraine and
there's no reason for us to be facing
this kind of additional
pressure on on vulnerable populations
around the world
one reaction that everyone should have
is outrage
you know outrage that in a world
in this
century in this modern world that we
have
this amount of people let alone one
person going starving that's
unacceptable so that outrage needs to
lead to
pressure
calls for attention to be given to the
situation and calls for resources to be
made available to address it
there's enough food around the world to
feed everybody on the planet
the issue is how do we get it to the
places it's needed
we're meeting the needs of around 130
million people around the world this
year we can feed them
that's not an issue we can get that food
we can move it to the places where it
needs to be but we need the funds to be
able to do that
[Music]